President Biden
took his State
of the Union message on the road
this week, trying out his new at
line, accusing some Republicans
of wanting
to sunset the federal programs.
Social Security and Medicare,
and set off a bitter,
bitter fight among Republican le
even as there is a bipartisan
push in the Senate
to try to make those entitlement
programs solvent.
And Senator Mike Rounds of South
Dakota joins us now.
Sara, thank you so much for join
President Biden out there
obviously on the campaign trail
as it were,
not officially
hitting Republicans all week on
Social Security.
And he's pointing
specifically to the plan
that your colleague,
Senator Rick Scott,
Republican of Florida, released
when he was
leading the Senate GOP's campaig
which says
just to quote,
all federal legislation sunsets
in five years
if a law is worth keeping,
Congress can pass it again, unqu
Do you support that plan?
I kind of look at Social Securit
the way I would
at the Department of Defense
and our Defense
Spending Board,
never going to not fund defense.
But at the same time,
we every single year
we look at how we can make it be
And I think it's about time that
talking about Social Security
and making it better.
We've got 11 years
before we actually see
cuts start to happen to people
that are on Social Security.
And I think it'd be very respons
for us to do everything
we can to make those funding pro
now and the plans right now
so that we don't run out of mone
in Social Security
and that it continues to provide
all the benefits that it does to
Simply looking away from it
and pretending
like there's
no problems with Social
Security is not an appropriate
or responsible thing to do.
So I guess my preference would b
let's start managing it
and I'll just give you an exampl
Later on today,
you're going to have folks
that are very successful
that are going to be around your
Why don't you ask them whether o
the funding
for their retirement
comes strictly from government b
or from from the government itse
And don't they look at other res
that help to make their their
retirement plans better?
And I think we can do that.
If we start now on a bipartisan
to make plans
so that we've got the resources
necessary,
if not in basically about 11 yea
and that's a
heads up for a lot of people
that are 50 51 52 years old, tha
the reductions that are built in
are about 24%.
A group of us are saying,
Look, we've got to do something
about that, let's talk about it.
And there's a group of us who ha
And so this is not something
that we should be talking,
trying to scare people.
This is something that we should
say, less plan now so that
Social Security
has a long run ahead of it
more than 75 years
and why don't we start
talking about the long term plan
instead of trying to scare one a
So I hear you on the long term p
and I want to
I want to talk about that in a s
But just to be clear about what
you were just talking about,
are you talking about
a partial privatization
of Social Security
so that there is an investment
in the market in addition
to government bonds?
Is that what I should understand
what you just said,
more along the lines
of allowing us to continue
to guarantee the benefits that a
but allow us to use other resour
to make sure that they are there
so that the individual doesn't
take the risk,
but rather that
the federal government does.
So rather than simply saying tha
and we've got a proven track rec
in other areas of the federal go
of doing this right now.
But there's a group of us
that have been working.
I'm not the leader of the group,
so I really don't want to get
into a lot of the detail on it.
But I really think there's
a golden opportunity in
in a bipartisan way
to put
Social Security on a long term p
That would make it better in the
than what it is today
and to assure its longevity.
But you do that by managing it.
You do that
by actually talking about it
and not you know, doing doing do
Every time somebody says,
let's try to address managing it
and look where
we've got right now
out of a $5.9 trillion federal b
The legislative part of this who
the Congress
actually only votes on about 1.6
to 1.7 trillion of that amount.
That's being spent.
Wouldn't it be better
if we actually tried to manage
the rest of it as well
and to actually be able to provi
that management tool
that right now does not exist
So I hear what you're saying,
and you're calling out
President Biden
for what you call dog calls
trying to scare people.
But I guess the question is, is
didn't Senator Rick Scott
give an opening?
When you talk about
sunsetting every program,
you know
how it's
how tough it is to pass anything
through the House and Senate,
much less a major
government spending program
every five years.
Take a listen to what your leade
Republican Leader Mitch
McConnell,
had to say about Rick Scott's
plan on Kentucky radio.
Just a couple of days ago,
there were no plans
to raise taxes
on half the American people
or to sunset Medicare or Social
So it's clearly the Rick Scott p
It is not the Republican plan,
and it's just a bad idea.
Yeah,
I think it will be a challenge f
to deal with this
in his reelection
in Florida State
with more elderly people
than any other state in America.
You've known Senator McConnell
a long time.
He doesn't
criticize fellow Republicans
very often,
let alone a common like that
about Rick Scott's reelection.
Are you worried that Rick Scott
hurt the party
with this plan
and is hurting the conversation
that you want to have
You know,
we do want to continue the conve
in terms
of how we make Medicare,
Medicaid better and long term su
I think Senator Scott had an ide
that he proposed.
I think the vast majority of us
that we'd prefer
to look at it in a different dir
One of managing it,
as opposed to a discussion
about having everything start ov
And I think that's misleading
in terms of what
he really intended to do.
But look,
the bottom line
is, is Republicans
want to see social security be s
and be improved.
And the best way to do
that is to take a look
at other successful pension prog
that the vast majority of us,
including a lot of the folks
that you're going to be talking
to, would include in their portf
But we can do that
as long as the federal governmen
continues to make the assurances
to the individuals
who are looking forward
to Social Security long term.
But once again,
in the next 11 years,
we have to have a better plan in
than what we do today
or we're going to see
under existing circumstances
some reductions of as much as 24
and some sort of a benefit.
So let's start talking now
because it's easier to fix it no
than it would be five years
or six years from now.
And that's the message
we're trying to get.
Is this
isn't it responsible
for Congress to actually say,
we're going to start
managing this,
we're going to try to do
our best to make it better?
So do you think
do you
think that everything
needs to be on the table in term
of managing it, in terms of mean
testing in terms of raising
the retirement age, in terms of,
you know, reducing benefits for
who may be financially or not
as dependent upon them and on an
Everything needs to be talked ab
I think the first thing that you
is you assure people
that are currently on Social Sec
or that are within 15,
20 years of getting it,
that they're not going to see ch
in the existing benefits or prog
I think that's really important
so that they can continue on the
that they've got for retirement.
And second of all,
you have to do a little bit
of looking
at what longevity looks like
and whether or not people,
if they're living longer,
do we have to plan to make sure
that we've got the resources
to be able to pay for those bene
long term?
There are some natural
things that we've done in the pa
We've looked at moving up
by a couple of months,
the the time period
in which full benefits start.
That's
possibly something
that we could look at in the fut
There may be some possibilities
of changing the amount of income
which is subject
to Social Security taxes.
I think those are reasonable
discussions to talk about.
Because right now
we have
some increases
there built into the existing pr
But let's not talk
about significant stuff
until we actually look at
what the other alternatives are.
We think that
there are possibilities
out there of long term success
without scaring people
and without tearing apart
the system and without reducing
But it requires management
and it requires
actually looking at
and making things better.
In South Dakota,
we've got the South
Dakota retirement plan
It's one of the best plans
in the entire nation.
But every single year
we try to make it better.
We try to do the internal mechan
so that we actually make it bett
than it was the year before. Rig
I'll bet
you can't find
anybody in South Dakota
that has that plan that isn't sa
with the direction
that we've done to make it bette
each year.
An important conversation.
Senator Mike Rounds,
we really appreciate your time t
Thank you.